the internet is an insane place i've
seen a lot of wild [ __ ] during my
lifetime on the internet but i may have
seen the absolute dumbest comments in
the world recently as a bunch of idiots
started to ask elon musk to shut off
teslas in russia literally i'm not
making this up here's one can you turn
off tesla and russia as a sort of tech
embargo we've got another one that says
elon musk hey why don't you turn off all
the teslas in russia if they aren't
moving shut them all down only going to
hurt the elite there you know and then
of course lastly please turn off all
teslas in russia the rich people need to
feel pressured into rebelling against
putin his actions cannot go unpunished
this is absolutely ridiculous why don't
we just go ahead and ask apple shut down
all the phones why don't we just kill
the internet actually why don't we just
stop feeding all of the people you know
that would put a lot of pressure on them
too of course at the end of the day what
we need to be doing is focusing on what
the intended goal is we shouldn't be
advocating for the censorship of private
companies for the average citizen there
are about 150 million citizens in russia
most of them don't agree with the war
they're out in the squares literally
chanting that they don't want their
country going to war ultimately we
shouldn't try to punish the everyday
citizen instead we should stay focused
on punishing the bureaucrats the
oligarchs and the politicians if you
want to affect change go after the
people who are making the decisions the
morons on the internet they're asking
elon musk to go ahead and shut off the
test laws i'm glad they're not running
public policy i'm glad they're not the
ones who are coming up with the sanction
and i'm glad that they're just running
pseudonymous accounts from their mom's
basement because ultimately this is a
stupid idea and i'm glad elon's smart
enough to just ignore the noise hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time